fue en el último vídeo que calculamos de
apareció total de estos nueve números
que tenemos aquí y de resultado nos dio
30 y a esto le llamamos la suma total de
cuadrados una vez que ya calculamos esto
lo que hicimos fue fijarnos en qué es lo
que pasaba con la suma de cuadrados
dentro de cada uno de los grupos es
decir nos fijamos en los elementos de
cada uno de los grupos con respecto a la
media de cada uno de los grupos y con
esto obtuvimos la suma de cuadrados
dentro lo cual no resultó 6 es decir de
estas 30 unidades de cambio o parís un
total que teníamos 6 vienen de la
medición dentro de cada uno de los
grupos después nos fijamos en la
variación que hay entre cada uno de los
grupos y obtuvimos 24 es decir de toda
la aparición total que teníamos 24
unidades vienen de la presión entre
grupos lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es llegar a algún tipo de conclusión y
qué mejor que una conclusión matemática
o una conclusión estadística
entonces para ello voy a necesitar su
imaginación vamos a suponer que estos
tres grupos son distintos tipos de
alimentos o tres tipos distintos de
comida
cuáles se van a dar en una prueba a
cierto tipo de personas y estos son los
resultados que obtuvieron y bueno como
ya quedamos en algo para no irnos
confundiendo vamos a ponerles nombre
este es el alimento número uno este es
el alimento número 2 y este va a ser
nuestro alimento número 3 muy bien ya
tenemos los tres tipos de alimentos y
entonces la pregunta es la siguiente las
diferencias en los resultados afectan la
prueba es decir miren las medias de cada
alimento si decimos que una es mejor que
otra entonces esta diferencia entre cada
alimento es puramente aleatoria o esta
información me da una preferencia en la
población sobre el alimento 3 versus el
alimento 2 versus el alimento 1 es decir
me pregunta qué sería si las medias de
cada alimento nos dicen exactamente lo
mismo esto quiero decir en términos
matemáticos y ojo no hablo de la media
del alimento 1 que es 2 me refiero a la
verdadera media poblacional es todavía
que mi pregunta va a ser de modo
matemático si la media de la población
que prueba el alimento 1 es igual a la
media del alimento 2 obviamente no sería
óptimo hablar
que diéramos a probar este alimento a
cada ser humano que esté vivo y de todos
estos tuviera yo mi ejemplo esto no
tendría sentido pues necesitamos una
media verdadera que sea medible es decir
mi pregunta es la media de la población
que pruebe el alimento 1 es igual a la
media de la población que prueba el
alimento 2 y está fuera igual a la media
de la población que prueba el alimento 3
si estas tres medias son iguales esta es
mi gran incógnita de este vídeo y bueno
qué quiere decir que no fuera cierta
esta afirmación eso quiere decir que
existe algún alimento el cual influyó en
los resultados de esta prueba o dicho de
otra manera es decir que estos tipos de
comida impactan sobre cómo la gente
realiza esta prueba tal vez así sea
mucho más claro si nosotros entendemos
la proposición negativa tal vez sea
mucho más fácil entender la proposición
afirmativa y para esto para resolver
esta duda voy a utilizar la prueba de
hipótesis entonces mi hipótesis es que
la comida o el alimento no implica o no
va a ser una diferencia a esta vamos a
llamarle hipótesis nula y vamos a tener
una hipótesis alterna
que diga que sí que si hace la
diferencia ahora bien que la hipótesis
nula se cumpla implica que la verdadera
media de la población que prueba el
alimento 1 es igual a la media de la
población que prueba la alimentados y es
igual a la media de población que prueba
el alimento 3 y bueno como la hipótesis
nula y la hipótesis alternativa chocan
entre sí es decir son contrarias lo que
quiere decir la hipótesis alternativa es
que no van a ser iguales las medias las
verdaderas medias de las poblaciones y
bueno es que aquí viene algo muy
importante porque si nosotros observamos
que h 0 y h1 chocan entre sí eso quiere
decir que no pueden ser ambas verdaderas
al mismo tiempo por lo tanto vamos a
asumir oa suponer que h 0 es verdadera
en un inicio y vamos a ver si llegamos a
una contradicción o no entonces vamos a
suponer que h 0 es verdadera y para ver
si es cierto que h 0 es verdadera o en
su dado caso que llegamos una
contradicción voy a utilizar la
estadística f o la aif estadística que
no es ni más ni menos que suponer que
estamos en una distribución
efe
esto quiere decir y no voy a entrar en
muchos detalles de qué es una
distribución
efe lo que sí quiero recordarles es que
esta distribución se comporta como el
cociente de dos distribuciones cuadradas
divididas entre sus grados de libertad
los cuales pueden o no pueden ser los
mismos
por ejemplo en este caso lo que vamos a
dividir es la suma de cuadrados entre
los grupos dividido entre sus grados de
libertad que habíamos dicho que eran en
menos 1 y es por eso que los le conoce
como la ms ya esto lo vamos a dividir
entre la suma de cuadrados dentro que
está aquí arriba la suma de cuadrados
dentro que es ssd dividido entre sus
grados de libertad que habíamos
calculado que eran m por n
1 m por n 1 ahora bien lo primero que
quiero que veamos es que si el numerador
es decir la suma de cuadrados entre es
mucho más grande que el denominador que
es la suma de cuadrados dentro esto
quiere decir que la variación la
variación total de nuestro problema
apareció en total de nuestro problema
bien
en su mayoría de la variación que hay
entre los grupos en lugar de la
variación que hay dentro de cada uno de
los grupos esto es en el caso de que el
numerador sea mucho más grande que el
denominador y entonces como este número
es muy grande quiere decir que la
variación entre los grupos es muy grande
lo que quiere decir que entonces la
verdadera media poblacional es muy
grande y eso hace entender que la
hipótesis nula tiene una probabilidad
muy poca o muy chica de que sea cierta
ahora bien qué es lo que pasa si es al
revés si el denominador es mucho más
grande que el numerador pues esto quiere
decir que entonces la aparición que hay
entre cada uno de los grupos es muy
pequeña a comparación de la variación
que hay dentro de cada uno de los grupos
lo que me está diciendo que él apareció
en total o la variación que estamos
calculando en la distribución
efe va a ser muy pequeña y lo que quiere
decir que la verdadera media poblacional
es muy pequeña y eso quiere decir que
entonces la hipótesis nula es muy
probable o tiene una probabilidad muy
grande de que ocurra
y bueno es hora de dejar de suponer y
empezar a calcular la cantidad de suma
de cuadrados entre los grupos será 24
entre 2 grados de libertad y esto lo
dividimos en 36 que era la suma de
cuadrados dentro de cada grupo ya esto
hay que dividirlo entre los grados de
libertad de la suma de cuadrados dentro
de cada grupo que también es 6 y esto es
bueno 24 entre 2 está fácil es 12 y
dividido entre 6 entre 6 que es muy
fácil que es 1 por lo tanto la
estadística o la estadística efe que
tiene una distribución
efe y efe en honor al científico
matemático biólogo inglés
ronald fischer y por lo tanto mi
estadística efe es igual a 12 que es un
bonito un hermoso número grande que por
cierto a todo esto se le conoce como la
prueba
efe de fisher y antes de proseguir es
necesario obtener una significación
estadística que para esta prueba voy a
decir que este nivel de significación es
el 10 por ciento o dicho de otra manera
alfa es igual a 0.10 y la significación
estadística es ni más ni menos que si
suponemos la hipótesis nula
lo que ya obtuvimos el resultado de la
prueba de fisher entonces existe una
probabilidad menor o igual al 10% de
rechazar la hipótesis nula por lo tanto
lo que buscamos es un valor crítico o
extremo estadístico tal que para
cualquier valor igual o mayor a él
tenemos una probabilidad del 10% y
entonces podemos rechazar la hipótesis
nula y no voy a invocar a los dioses de
la estadística para entender lo que
sucede aquí pero lo que sí quiero
decirles es que tenemos dos divisiones
que cuadraran esta es una distribución
cuadrada y ésta aquí es otra
distribución distinta y cuadrada y
esencialmente nos podemos dar cuenta que
son distintas por dos grados de libertad
mientras que en la en la he cuadrada de
arriba tenemos dos grados de libertad en
la de abajo tenemos seis grados de
libertad por lo tanto lo que voy a
utilizar ahora es una página de internet
de un curso de un profesor de la
universidad de california en los ángeles
en la cual podemos observar una tabla y
de hecho se dan cuenta también aquí está
la gráfica de la distribución
efe de la distribución de fisher la cual
va a depender de la cantidad de grados
de libertad que tenemos en el
denominador y en él
en este caso en el numerador tenemos dos
dedos de libertad y en el denominador
tenemos seis grados de libertad y
esencialmente lo que buscamos en esta
página de internet es aquel valor
crítico tal que para cualquier valor
mayor o igual que el dado que tenemos
una significación estadística del 10%
entonces puede rechazar nuestra
hipótesis nula de hecho hay tablas
distintas y variados el valor de alfa y
también hay que tener en cuenta los
grados de libertad que en este caso son
2 y 6 entonces lo primero que vamos a
ver es que esta tabla corresponde a la
alfa igual al 10% identificarnos en los
grados de libertad en el numerador
tenemos dos grados de libertad y en el
denominador tendríamos seis grados de
libertad por lo tanto mi valor crítico
que nosotros buscamos para esta prueba
de fisher es 3.46 33 3.46 vamos a
redondear por lo tanto este de aquí es
nuestro punto 3.46 y entonces como
tenemos un valor de 2 el cual es mucho
más grande que 3.46 tenemos una
probabilidad casi nula muy pequeña de
que se cumpla la hipótesis nula tenemos
una probabilidad muy pequeña
por lo tanto lo que podemos hacer es
rechazar completamente de hipótesis nula
entonces vamos a rayar la hipótesis nula
y esto quiere decir que no se vale esto
es decir que las medias de la población
que prueban un cierto alimentos no son
iguales lo que nos dice que es muy
probable que las medias de la población
sean diferentes si les damos a probar
los diferentes alimentos en el ejemplo
que pusimos